[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chance of death to arabs
anger and hate has spilled out onto the
streets in the coastal city of battiam
palestine israelis and jewish israelis
living in close proximity
turning on each other
among many violent incidents on
wednesday a palestinian man
was dragged from his car by dozens of
jewish israelis
who continued to beat him even after he
lost consciousness
the video is broadcast live on israeli
television
and closer to tel aviv palestinian
businesses were ransacked
the wave of violence has hit dozens of
cities and regions across israel
it's the worst between communities
living alongside each other
in decades israeli officials say they
are more violent
than the protests that led to the
al-aqsa intifada in 2000.
tension came to a boiling point as a
court prepared to rule on the force
expulsion of palestinian families from
their homes
in the occupied east jerusalem sheikh
jarrah neighborhood
israeli journalist yossi melman says
he's worried about vigilante groups
inside israel running a mark
he says they're headed to the abyss as a
result of absence of governance
and years of incitement and prime
minister benjamin netanyahu
has asked both sides to stop the attacks
in an attempt to quell the violence
netanyahu ordered the emergency
deployment of border forces
but police tactics are under scrutiny
after this video was shared on social
media
of officers storming a family home in
the northern city of haifa
they can be seen beating an unarmed
palestinian-israeli man
and to the south of tel aviv the city of
lord has been put under a state of
emergency
the first in an arab community since
1966
it's been one of the worst hit by riots
on tuesday night jewish cars and a
synagogue were satellite
a mosque was burned the next day
and palestinian musa hasuna was shot
dead by jewish residents during protests
even though the court has postponed the
hearing on sheikh jarrah
many are now more worried about how to
stop the violence
caused by anger that's been simmering
for much longer
laura burden manly al jazeera well
mickey rosenfeld is israel's police
national spokesman to foreign media
joins us now
from west jerusalem good to have you
with us so the latest tension started
with
fears concern that israeli police
might uphold an israeli court order and
forcibly evict palestinians from
neighborhood as well as
actions administrative and security
measures taken by
israel in east jerusalem around the
al-aqsa mosque compound my question to
you though
sir do you accept that you are an
occupying power
which the this is according to the un
you are an occupying power which has no
legal authority
to impose israeli law in these occupied
territories
uh israel and the country that we live
in is a country that belongs to the
jewish people
with the history of thousands of years
back
uh israel and the different units and
i'm referring to the idf and the israeli
national police will do everything
possible in order to maintain public
order
and prevent large-scale incidents from
taking place
in jerusalem if we look back just last
year when we were dealing here in israel
with kovitt 19 ramadan was very peaceful
and very calm and quiet last year okay
over the last two with me but but then
what you're telling
viewers is people like the official
spokesperson rupert culver for the un
office
of the high commissioner for refugees
when he said on may the 7th
2021 and i quote
given the disturbing scenes in sheikh
jarrah over the past few days
we wish to emphasize that east jerusalem
remains part of the occupied palestinian
territory
in which international humanitarian law
applies
and the occupying power must respect
unless
absolutely prevented the laws in the
force in the country you're saying
to viewers that in fact he's wrong
because as you said
this is your country you don't recognize
that you're an occupation
what i'm saying is we're not an occupied
force this country belongs to israel is
this israel is a strong
unique and humanitarian country at the
moment
you've taken out of proportion the
israeli arabs unfortunately with inside
jerusalem
have taken out of proportion a dispute
about sheikh
there are many disputes that take place
in many different areas but they can be
solved
by the israeli courts whatever the
israeli courts will decide
will be accepted both by the jewish
families that live there as well as by
the israeli-palestinian families that
live there as well
i'm going back to the point that we made
which what happened just two weeks ago
on the temple mount
thousands of palestinians arrived there
and instead of celebrating
they gathered rocks and stones and
attacked our police officers and jewish
worshippers at the western wall that is
something that is unacceptable
as a response our police units went
inside the temple mount area
only used non-lethal weapons and
dispersed that riot
that is something that we've dealt with
many times you haven't
jumped in many times if you let me jump
in but unesco
says on point five of its may the second
2017 ruling that quote
legislative and administrative measures
and actions taken by israel
the occupying power
it says are especially says in
particular quote the basic law in
jerusalem are null and void
and must be rescinded forth with do you
recognize
that it's because of your interventions
in the the al-aqsa mosque compound in
east jerusalem
that is provoking the reaction from the
palestinians you're complaining about
do you recognize that
i have to confirm and make it clear to
your viewers as well
the issue of the temple mount the temple
mount the status quo will be
kept and held and will continue
by israel this quarter thank you so
israel
is unesco wrong in saying that you
your attempts to enforce the basic law
in jerusalem intervene
in as you call it temple mountain
palestinians call it the al-aqsa mosque
compound a null and void
do you recognize that yes or no my
answer
i will answer you and my answer is is
that the israeli national police and the
israeli government
is making sure that the status quo on
the temple mount will continue
this is one of the issues that we're
dealing with people are praying on the
temple mount and i'm talking about
muslims five times a day in peace and
quiet in a respectable manner
asking answering the question about
whether you recognize what u.n
organizations are saying let me quote to
you then instead what human rights
watchers said in its report
of june 4th 2017 israeli authorities
have since 1967 facilitated the transfer
of civilians to the occupied
west bank do you accept what u.n
organizations what human rights
organizations are saying
you are an occupying power that is
violating international law
i can see that you've gathered and put
together all the quotes
the point is is you and people have to
understand and realize you're not
talking and interviewing me
in uh 1967. we're talking about 2021.
sir colville in may the 7th 2021 and i
have done my research and i make no
apology for it
these need to be addressed okay i
understand that are you are you
saying to viewers the un unesco
amnesty international i've got a quote
here if you want to hear it where they
where they say settling civilians in
occupied territories violates
international humanitarian law and
amounts to a war crime are you telling
viewers the un
the international court of justice
amnesty international human rights watch
are
all wrong and only you are right i'm
saying
no what i'm saying is is that jerusalem
so you said no
if they're not wrong then you admit that
you are an occupying power that is
violating international law by your
interventions
i heard your question and i will answer
your question now
israel is in charge and is responsible
and is making decisions as to what takes
place here in jerusalem both west
and east jerusalem together in the
different neighborhoods and the
different areas
israel is fully in control of dealing
with everything
in terms of security israel is
protecting the israeli
jewish citizens as well as israeli arabs
who are living in the different areas
and the neighborhoods
our responsibility is also to protect
to make sure that there are no frictions
between the different size the different
communities
i'm going back to a very important point
which is a sensitive point
which is what happened on the temple
mount we saw thousands of palestinians
taking the law into their own hands and
attacking officers
and attacking other areas that is
something that is unacceptable
and the israeli police officers right in
and around who are guarding the three
most holiest sites
the temple mount the western war and the
church of
the sepulcher are making sure that we're
doing everything to prevent
large-scale incidents right you're
describing to me
what you're doing i don't think you've
really addressed the point
and the question i've put you of whether
you recognize what these organizations
are saying that what you're
what you're doing is taking the law into
your own hands but i'm afraid
we are out of time thank you very much
for explaining your perspective we'll
leave it to the viewers to draw their
conclusions
thank you